والله ما بعرف وينه ههه
مكسورا فاقدا للحيله امامها للواقع حتى
وان نجحت خطط ازاله هذا الدمار الذي خلفه
الزلزال سريعا ستظل قصص ماسيه مستمره ماس
انسانيه لاشخاص امثال عمر ماتت زوجته
وابنه تحت هذا الركام فيما نجا هو ودخل
لحظتها في رحله بحث عن ابنه الثاني
المفقود
هاي لعبه ابني
والله لعبه اشتريت له يا بايدي هاي لعبته
اليوم يقول ليتني ما نجوت
ايقاف فرق الانقاذ بحثها عن ابنه المفقود
بعد تيقنها من عدم وجوده تحت هذه الانقاذ
منحه املا في العثور عليه حيه والغرفه
الصالون فتشنا كل البيت ما لقينا شيء
الديوانات
والسداجه طلعت وابني ما طلع ما لقيته ابني
[موسيقى]
تميت يومين لاطلعت
والحمد لله رب العالمين باتمنى من الجميع
ان يعرف خشي الاتراك صاحب البيت يشوف
هالمكان ويعرف يعرفني انه انا عايش اذا
ابني معه يا رب يجيبه او يعطيني خبر عليه
تمضي ساعات والايام وربما الاسابيع لكن
الزمن عند عمر متوقف الى حين لقاء ابنه
شعله امله الوحيده للحياه
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه